[Applause]
good
morning well we are here
to join as Floridians to say that uh we
need to stop this Invasion at our
Southern border once and for all
and we're here we've got a number of
folks that are joining us uh today we
have a general John hos who's our
agitant General the Florida National
Guard we have executive director of the
highway safety Motor Vehicles Department
which oversees Highway Patrol uh Dave
kerer uh we have uh director mark themi
from the Florida state guard uh and then
we have uh Sergeant Anthony uh deich uh
an FHP Trooper who has been deployed to
the southern border and then we have
Gary how Colonel Gary how's director of
the Florida Highway Patrol go back to
January 20th
2021 uh what is Joe Biden do as soon as
he gets into office he opens the
southern border uh he says he's not
going to deport people for 100 days he
issues a slew of executive orders to not
just not have the Border be fortified
but really to invite people uh to come
in and when he was running for president
he had said that people are going to be
able to come in and he created an
environment where you could pay some
kyote thousands of dollars and just get
to that border and you're home free and
so we've seen a huge increase uh over
many years and now it's as bad as it's
ever been at the southern border we
understood this problem in Florida uh
right at the beginning in 2021 and so as
this was happening uh Texas was
scrambling to defend its people and
defend its state and they needed
assistance they weren't getting any
assistance from the Federal Government
Federal Government was acting to thwart
what they were trying to do so uh we
stepped up all the way back in 2021 and
we've had people on the ground there uh
since 2021 we've had National Guard
we've had Highway Patrol fish and
wildlife Florida Department of Law
Enforcement you you name it uh they have
been there and they've been making a big
big difference and they've been able to
see a lot of the things that are
happening you we have our our folks from
FHP they're stopping people from Iran
coming across the border Morocco all
these places around the world which is
just crazy that this is happening uh and
and director ker can talk about he's got
a whole laundry list of things they just
had an alien from Mexico uh that they
picked up near the border who was out
who was wanted for capital murder in the
Houston area uh so so this has been a
total disaster you have massive amounts
of drugs pouring into the border and
then the sheer number of people you know
you don't hear these cities talk about
being Sanctuary cities anymore do you
because they realize you can't possibly
take this many people uh coming in so
we've been uh assisting from the
beginning uh We've also taken steps here
in the State of Florida uh We've sign
strong legislation to protect Floridians
against illegal immigration including
Banning Sanctuary cities including
having e verify for employers including
increasing penalties for human
trafficking and human smuggling uh We've
also banned local governments and
non-government organizations from
issuing ID cards to illegal aliens um
and we've invalidated outof state
licenses that have been issued to
illegal aliens by States like California
we're not recognizing that here in the
State of Florida um and so we've been
very very strong on this we understand
the costs involved uh and there are many
many costs we now have more uh fenel
deaths on a DA on a yearly basis than
we've ever had it's been going up and up
uh we've done a lot to stop that here in
Florida we've had some success in
slowing slowing the problem but when you
have this much coming in I mean I I
think they just did what was it 15,000
pills that they just seized uh in
Florida fenyl pills they were disguised
as oxycotton they were really fentol and
just so and I've been doing this now for
years raising the alarm on it when you
talk to parents who've lost kids from
fenol poisoning a lot of times s it's in
one of those situations they think
they're taking an oxy cotton or
something which you know they shouldn't
be doing but if it's Lac with fenol you
could be poisoned to death right there
so all of those fake oxycotton with that
or fentol you know those are potential
death sentences to anyone that takes it
and so we see that and the the human
toll has been incredible that this is
happening Biden has the authority to
close this border today if he wanted to
he lacks the will to get the job done he
lacks the capacity to see the problem
for what it is and to get the job done
and so the American people are basically
left scrambling uh and they're left to
have to deal with this uh all on their
own now we've done a lot uh FHP Troopers
uh since 2021 they've intercepted
150,000 illegal aliens
[Applause]
um
and they have been instrumental in
generating over
2,000 human trafficking and human
smuggling charges in the state of Texas
our National Guard have helped staff
observation points patrols uh and they
have helped with fencing and barriers uh
our Florida Department of Law
Enforcement has assisted Texas DPS with
arrest of uh criminal aliens including
violent gang members and Florida Fish
and Wildlife has deployed
hundreds of officers over 500 four-wheel
drive Patrol trucks and 24 vessels to
assist in patrolling the Border along
the Rio Grand River so we have stepped
up probably more than any other state
has stepped up and we're proud to do
that however uh we don't think this is
enough uh I believe that a state has a
right to fortify its own borders uh and
so if Texas is helping to erect barriers
putting up razor wire doing other things
to keep illegal aliens out I want to be
helpful with them doing that I don't
want to be part of the federal
government trying to tear down these
barriers and let more people in
illegally this is crazy that this is the
case uh so today uh we are going to
fortify our presence along the southern
border uh we're providing up to one
battalion of Florida National Guard uh
as well as uh our first ever deploy
employment of the Florida State guard
and the goal is to help Texas fortify
this border help them strengthen the
barricades help them add barriers help
them add the wire that they need to so
that we can stop this Invasion once and
for all and the states have to band
together the states have to band
together uh to be able to defend the
rule of law and and we see the problems
the drugs the crime just the sheer
number of people what has that done to
hospitals what has it done to education
it's just you just can't do it I mean we
probably have had 10 million come
illegally since Biden's been president
but that number even if that was legal
we cannot absorb that many people it's
just not the way you you do business
it's not the way you run a country uh
but it's also a larger issue you know if
we don't have a border then we are not a
sovereign country uh you either you
either have a border or you don't you're
either either a sovereign country or
you're
not so what we're doing today is uh
we're stepping up yet again we're
helping uh and I know other states have
done a lot and I I'm pretty sure some of
these other states are going to do more
uh but what Joe Biden's Administration
has done is wrong what they continue to
try to do is wrong uh and his failure to
do his duty and satisfy his oath of
office um is something that um
represents one of the biggest failures
of this administ ation and that's saying
something because there've been a lot so
let's let's all band together as States
let's say that our borders matter let's
say that we're going to support Texas uh
in making sure that we can stop what is
happening to our country so I'm proud to
be able to have a lot of people that
have served from Florida over these last
almost three years now uh we're going to
have more that are going to go and
they're going to do a great job and this
is important this is one of the most
important issues happening in our
country today you know the people in DC
they may not think this is that
important because it doesn't affect them
you know they're more concerned about
sending your money overseas or doing
whatever they is that they do uh but
this is really important to the American
people and if you look at the the
potential border deal that they're
talking about where they're going to do
some type of Reform first of all Biden
doesn't need legislation to do what he's
going to do second of all they're saying
oh you can have you shut the border down
only if you get more than 5,000 illegal
aliens a day well that's a million eight
a year 1.8 million a year that you're
just saying is fine that that's an
acceptable amount of illegal entries to
me the only acceptable amount of illegal
entries is zero and that's what our
policy should
reflect so uh what they're doing up in
DC I mean look a lot of that is they're
working for their interests uh when you
start talking about green lighting that
many more illegal entries I can tell you
like this has been a hot issue I've
spoken with people all over the country
in the last few years about this I've
never had one person say that what we
needed to do is what they're thinking
about doing in Washington not one person
has ever said that um at all because
they're not concerned about you they're
not concerned about our country they're
concerned about their own interest so
we're going to bring up some other folks
here but I'm excited to be able to make
this announcement uh we're doing our
part uh I've said from 2021 when I used
to say that this is an American issue
it's not just a border issue you know a
lot of people in the media would sneer
and now look what's happened look where
we are now uh as a country it's sad that
this has happened uh but we're gonna not
just going to sit idly by we're going to
do something about it all right I'm
going to bring up some folks so we'll
start with uh Dave Kerner from Florida
uh Department of Highway Safety and
Motor
[Applause]
Vehicles Governor there's not really
much more that I could add about the
description and the conditions at our
Southern border but I'd like to start by
a thanking you as our governor and as
our leader uh not just uh as the
executive director but as as a Floridian
as a a resident of the State uh for
proactively uh taking the mission to the
Texas Board protecting Floridians first
and putting the state first you've
always done that as our governor and
we're honored to work for you sir thank
you for what you've done I'd also like
to say thank you to the men and women
behind me who have served on the border
you know I did some basic math of
Florida Highway Patrol and our state
troopers have served over 30,000
individual day and nights away from
their families away from their state
away from their duties here having said
that they are never more committed than
they are now to be on the board
protecting this state these these men
and women behind me they see the impact
of the open border not just while
they're there but we have 2,000 state
troopers in the State of Florida that
Patrol these roadways and put bad people
in jail every day they see the 50 15,000
fentanyl pills they see the 30 pounds of
methamphetamine that were just seized
last week they've never seen this type
of uh drug interdiction in in their
entire careers and so Governor we remain
committed to this Mission we're honored
to be a part of this Mission and we know
that it's a mission of a lifetime and
director in general we're certainly
excited to have you join us in your
capacity to protect the border of the
United States and to protect the
families and uh and constitutionality
and sovereignty of the State of Florida
thank you Governor
thanks
you know if you look at like some of the
write up that FHP you know does in terms
of some of the U interactions that
they've had you know they had one
instance recently where illegal alien
took I think like a one-year-old and and
threw the one-year-old into the Rio
Grand to try to get people to come and
then I think they thought they could hop
on the boat and get across the border
someone came tried to rescue then then a
lady dropped I think like a
four-year-old or something and then that
and it was and they ended up it didn't
succeed you know the the kids were
rescued but then they put them back on
the other side of the Border but I'm
just thinking like who would throw a
one-year-old into a river like that I
mean like this is just really really
nuts and we have no idea who the heck
these people are who are coming um do
you think they're getting background
checks uh do you think they're showing
ID you know you if you want to get on a
commercial flight in this country you
know you got to get a basically a cavity
search you got to show ID you got to go
through all the secur these illegals
don't even need photo ID they can fly on
our planes without photo ID you talk
about putting the American people last
what the hell are we doing in this
country it is a total
farce
[Applause]
General good morning Governor de santis
agency Chiefs distinguished guests and
fellow service members I'm proud to say
that the Florida National Guard is ready
once again to answer the call in
partnership with our fellow state agency
teammates in support of our of the
citizens of Texas and the Texas National
Guard for several years the Florida
National Guard has supported ongoing
border security missions in Texas to
include deployments in support of
multiple federal and state mobilizations
last spring the Florida National Guard
was the first in a nation to
mobilize rotational units to the
Southwest border in support of operation
lonar during the deployments the Florida
National Guard provided over 700
soldiers to support border security
operations and today as directed by our
governor and commander-in-chief we're
again mobilizing the Florida National
Guard to provide up to a battalion siiz
multi-purpose task force to support the
security operations along the Texas
border while continuing to provide
critical support to our citizens in the
state by conducting ongoing security
efforts and related Mission sets here in
Florida to include interdiction missions
supporting the Florida Highway Patrol
continued staff support for the
Department of Corrections and sustained
Aviation support in the Florida
Keys I thank the brave men and women of
the Florida National Guard their
families and the employers who continue
to serve and support the great state and
Nation the Florida National Guard is
always up to the task and will represent
the State of Florida well in this very
important mission our governor has a
unique military perspective because he
has served our country in uniform as a
naval officer and Judge Advocate General
he knows firsthand the dedication and
discipline required for Missions such as
this Governor thank you for your
leadership and for the confidence and
enduring support of your soldiers and
Airmen who proudly serve and answer the
call whenever and wherever needed sir
your Florida National Guard is always
ready always there
thanks
all right
[Applause]
director good morning all and thank you
Governor Dan santis for your unflinching
leadership uh and the opportunity to
help mitigate the overwhelming threat to
Public Safety that is illegal
immigration as the country fights back
against the Border crisis at the Florida
state guard we are prepared to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with our team
teammates in the Florida National Guard
the Florida Highway Patrol the Florida
departments of law enforcement and Fish
and
Wildlife to provide direct support to
our brothers and sisters in Texas who
are grappling with an unprecedented
surge of illegal immigration that
threatens their borders and their
interior during idalia and other severe
weather events uh during this season our
soldiers demonstrated emergency response
capabilities as reliable and
professional partners responding to all
threats to Public Safety since
reactivation of the Florida State guard
our soldiers have been trained and
credentialed in emergency response and
Public Safety and humanitarian
assistance
operations our response to the
governor's call to action in support of
Texas is deeply rooted in our unwavering
commitment to support Public Safety in
times of need the dangers of the Border
crisis do not stop at state lines and
are far too great for any one state to
ignore or to overcome we and the Florida
state guard are postured to deliver
rapid response to any and all threats to
Public Safety wherever and whenever the
need arises thank you for your interest
and thank you for supporting our Florida
State Guard
soldiers all right
Sergeant thank you governor for having
us and uh I just like to bring a little
insight to the to the Border crisis that
we see on a day in and day out basis um
a lot of people don't cover it because
it doesn't um provide good news uh media
attention but at the end of the day what
we see on a day everyday basis is the
number of lives that are brought across
over to Florida to
Texas um by people of criminal
organizations and the criminal
organizations thrive
on the people trying to get them across
and you know ultimately it affects us
locally here in Florida because we're
stopping people with drugs we're
stopping people who are um bringing
weapons and things of that nature into
our communities um and having to deal
with these individuals on the side of
the road that have no regard for
anybody's life they don't care about um
anybody that we're they're bringing
across the the big picture for them is
making a profit and and um that we see
on a day in and day out basis so that's
why we're so willing to go across over
to Texas and and try to help prevent
those things from coming over to Florida
um a lot of people don't see it but like
they said 30 30 kilos of methamphetamine
just last week uh that we recovered off
of the roadway um that 30 kilos can kill
numerous numerous people and um a lot of
people that that doesn't get brought out
in in the media you know they don't tell
you that they're bringing 30 kilos or or
15,000 fent and all pills over so um we
appreciate the support of the governor's
office we appreciate the support of
Governor D santis and we'll continue to
do our mission over in Texas uh to help
protect the citizens of the State of
Florida so thank you thank you
appreciate
it well we're uh we're going to continue
doing our part uh this has been an
ongoing issue it's sad that it's uh that
it's gone on this long it's sad that you
know you don't have a president willing
to just you know put his foot down and
say I'm not going to let this happen to
my country uh but in the absence of that
uh leadership in the in the face of the
D elction of Duty we're going to step up
and do our part so uh you're going to
have Florida folks you have them there
now you're going to have more Florida
folks there because I think this is an
American issue I don't think it's one
State's issue and I think we have to we
have to do the right thing here so I'm
proud of what all these uh folks from
Florida have done over these last couple
years and I'm proud of what they're
going to do uh as we really come into a
really important inflection point about
whether we even going to be a country
anymore or not and I think if uh if
we're able to to help Texas fortify this
then then I think there there'll be a
lot of Hope for a lot of people so thank
you yes
sir Texas has the right to erect
barriers they were not even a party to
that decision and so uh I think they're
continu to do what they're going to do
and we are going to assist them in doing
that I mean just think about it you say
that the federal government has the
purview over uh illegal immigration uh
and borders uh and that states can't be
involved but the federal government's
not enforcing the law all the states are
trying to do is to actually enforce the
law um as as required and so so they're
not doing that um so so the federal
govern's not doing it so I think what
Texas is doing is just defending itself
I think that's a core attribute of
sovereignty to be able to do that uh but
uh and I know there's been some
misreporting on this the Texas was not
ordered to do anything to stop or to do
anything it was basically what the
federal government there had been an
injunction that was that was relieved
but I think it's ultimately going to be
up to Biden are you going to have folks
go in and forcibly remove barriers so
that more people can come in illegally I
don't know that that's a decision that
that that he would want to do
particularly now that we're in this
election year so I think Texas is in the
right I think they'll ultimately win if
they end up becoming a party to any type
of litigation and and I want to make
sure that we have we can serve as some
Force multipliers to get as much of that
border C fortified as possible yes
sir
well first of all uh we stood up for the
innocence and well-being of the children
of the State of Florida and that's the
right thing to
do I'm the I'm the father of young I
mean we got a first grader kindergarten
and a pre3 and so my wife and I believe
and I think the vast vast majority of
parents in Florida and throughout the
country believe kids should be able to
just be kids you go to school uh you're
not having an agenda shoved down your
throat you're not being told that you
can switch genders you're you're
focusing on the basics and so that was
ultimately the initial uh fight was
about that um you know Disney was
against it they were wrong we were right
and we did that then after that as as
their corporate welfare privileges came
under scrutiny in the legislature the
reality is the Florida legislature has
every right uh to change Special
Districts they've always had that right
um and think what's happened since since
there's been accountability now in that
area uh you know you had the board that
we appointed they've reduced the taxes
for all the tenant businesses that were
being taxed to basically service
Disney's interest that's not the
appropriate use of government government
is supposed to be something I mean
initially was supposed to have have
residential communities there so voters
would have picked who was on it that
obviously did never happen and and this
one company ended up taking control of
the the local government which is not
good government at all uh and so we so
we knew that the legislature had
authority to do it I had the authority
to sign the legislation as we did and
and I would like to you know see an
accounting from some of the people who
last year were trying to say that
somehow you know Disney had had had
outmaneuvered Florida or that somehow
they were in the right on all this you
heard a lot of squawking when they were
able to use it to try to attack Florida
or try to attack me I don't hear very
much now uh that the case was summarily
dismissed I mean they don't have a case
uh even if you assume everything they
say is true they do not have a case so
we absolutely anticipated this we knew
ultimately what we did uh would be
upheld uh they I'm shocked that they're
saying they're going to appeal it um I
think that's a mistake I think that they
should just kind of move on you're in
the state that's number one for business
in America right now uh we have the
lowest unemployment amongst large states
highest G GP growth amongst large states
is it so bad that you actually have to
live under the same laws as everybody
else including your competitors of
course not this is not a matter of high
principle for them this is a matter of
them trying to claw Back special
privileges that they were never entitled
to in the first
[Applause]
place
I have not seen the legislation but I've
been very clear ever since I've been
Governor I do not support taking down
monuments in this state we've got to
stop with this okay you know it's like
you you learn from history um and you do
that but to try to just say and here's
the thing when they'll say oh well like
five years ago it's like oh well we just
they just didn't want some Civil War
General or whatever and then now that's
turned into taking down Thomas Jefferson
and Teddy Roosevelt and Lincoln taking
Washington's name off schools that is it
is nuts and so I've just said no uh
we're not going to support uh removing
any monuments or taking down any
statutes we've created some protections
when we did the anti- rioting
legislation where because people were
trying to topple stuff so we added some
penalties there but I think it's totally
appropriate for the legislature to say
you know what we're going to stop the m
Madness uh we're not going to do I heard
people in in Jacksonville want to take
down Andrew Jackson what are we going to
rename the city I mean come on we've got
to stop doing this and I think that it's
just it's not something that's going to
end up working out well for us and
especially it's like you know who who's
next okay you're already up to like
Lincoln and Teddy Roosevelt I mean
you're going to go on and on there
because if you're going to if you're
going to apply some type of hyper woke
21st century test to pass people you
know you're going to run into turbulence
with MLK Jr you're going to run into
turbulence with a lot of people and it's
like is that really how we view history
no history is what it is uh you learn
from it and then and then you try to do
the best you can again going forward so
so I'm 100% against removing uh The
Monuments I think it's just uh it's just
gone too
far yeah so I have to look at that I
mean look anything that's been taken
down uh since I've been Governor uh I
that's not anything I've supported I
don't know how many have been I know
there's been controversy here in this
area I think it's been relatively minor
but but my view is is is you don't take
down um and so if someone is taken down
I think that that's a mistake yes
sir it's not targeting anybody it's just
we got to recognize what's the fact
okay you're born one way or another
there's only two okay you know I I get
this like thing where people say like
you know you have a baby and it's like a
gender assigned at Birth no no no no I
mean God's been doing this a while okay
it's either one or the other and that's
just what it is
now how someone conceives of themselves
and all that that is subjective okay and
so I think what we have to do from the
state perspective is just focus on the
objective biological realities
um because the minute you go off of that
the minute it can be subjective well
what else can be subjective and and
there's a whole host of other things
that you could just say is that so it's
not targeting anybody it's just how do
you have to to root your policy and I
think we just have to root our policy
and truth and in fact and so that's what
it is you're you're born one way or
you're born the other and that's just
how we got a
role
yes yeah I mean I think that uh in
contact with Texas DPS uh basically
Texas has had um this emac request it's
been pretty standard this is not
necessarily anything new uh that they've
needed support they've been asking for
support so it's in response to that but
I do think for us we really started
thinking about we've done a lot but we
saw what was happening with the
barricades and we wanted to make sure
those barricades uh could be erected and
so if our folks can help with that we
thought that that was something that was
very important so um so there they're
going to be working together uh exactly
where they'll go will really be done in
conjunction with Texas uh I anticipate
uh people will start moving out
relatively uh shortly uh and will likely
uh you know be be busting a lot of
people o over to the state of Texas so I
I think it's a great Mission it's
interesting of having talked to folks
who've done it you know there's a lot of
passion in this mission for for folks
I've talked to a lot of the FHP guys
FDLE uh you know it's not easy work
because you're away from your family
you're in and some of these places in
Texas you know South Texas as a native
Floridian I remember we did an event
there in June On the Border that was the
hottest I've ever been in my life hotter
than Iraq hotter than Florida in August
or September I mean it was really really
bad but then in the winter it actually
gets pretty cold uh too so it it's it's
in terms of the climate it can be
challenging and so we've had a lot of
guys that have been out there um that
have done really really well we
appreciate the service we know that
we're asking um you know to step up and
supplement what you're already doing I
want to thank all the agencies uh FHP I
want to thank FDLE I want to thank uh
National Guard you know they have day
jobs that they do here and so they're
not really um subtracting from anything
they're already doing they're still
doing all the stuff that they normally
do they're just doing extra duty to be
able to help this country so I think
that's really good service and
ultimately when you're involved in any
type of Public Service you know that's
what it's all about are you making a
difference in people's lives are not and
these folks are making a difference and
Florida is making a difference thanks
everybody God
bless than so much thank you thank you
God bless you
guys